[Music]
tonight House Republicans are dealing
with more internal struggles over
immigration a farm bill and a lame-duck
speaker with rapidly diminishing
influence all this comes ahead of a
pivotal pivotal elections in November of
course Peter Doocy sets the table for us
tonight from Capitol Hill morning this
speaker keeps getting turned down by
members of his own party this year will
be my last one and now the retiring
House Speaker Paul Ryan could be
squeezed out this summer by his
hand-picked successor Majority Leader
Kevin McCarthy the Office of Management
and Budget director Mick Mulvaney
revealed this weekend quote I've talked
with Kevin about this privately but not
as much publicly McCarthy says a Weekly
Standard report called quote a coup in
the offing is completely untrue
Paul has my total support but news of a
shuffle comes today that 20 Republicans
continued working with Democrats to
clinch enough signatures to go around
Ryan to force a series of votes on
immigration including a daca fix in less
than a week after the Ryan backed farm
bill failed this is the nature of the
Republican Conference we've got
conservatives and moderates and
whoever's in leadership they have to
curate that balance a Ryan spokeswoman
tells Fox quote this conference has
always had its ups and downs and the
speaker will continue to move us forward
as a team Paul Ryan himself has long
argued that members should want him
around for as long as possible because
he makes them so much money and it makes
no sense to take the biggest fundraiser
off the field still strategists see a
potential positive and swapping speakers
before the midterms and the plans have
reached the Trump administration because
director Mulvaney said this weekend
quote wouldn't it be great to force a
Democrat running in a tight race to have
to put up or shut up about voting for
Nancy Pelosi eight weeks before an
election that's a really really good
vote for us to force if we can figure
out how to do it but one Democratic
lawmaker who represents a district Trump
one doesn't see Pelosi as a liability I
don't think anybody on the Democratic
side of the aisle is is interested and a
bunch of upheaval at this point just a
few minutes ago Mulvaney's spokeswoman
emailed me to say that he was speaking
hypothetical hypothetically this weekend
and
is not working behind the scenes to oust
Ryan and if you look at the numbers
right now there is a reason that nobody
is publicly calling for a speaker's
election that is because nobody has
believed to have the votes to replace
him right now including McCarthy there
are still multiple factions of
Republicans that are gonna want
something in exchange for their support
to help him win a majority of the house
breath fascinating Peter Doocy live on
the hill Peter thank you